boys welcome to hannity breaking tonight
we are tracking multiple developing
stories including this one
yes from san francisco look at your
screen fox news has
exclusively obtained this security
footage showing nancy pelosi the speaker
of the house at least a name only
getting her hair done at a san francisco
salon despite
local officials forcing all salons to
remain
closed because of coronavirus concerns
well as per usual the rules don't apply
to nancy pelosi
the owner of that salon is infuriated we
have all of those details and video
coming up also tonight evidence has
emerged
that i yours truly and others were
illegally monitored
by our government full details and a
full report from john solomon
also tonight we'll do something the mob
and the media will never do
a special hannity investigation into the
democrats
radical socialist agenda we'll take a
deep dive tonight into the bernie biden
manifesto and later
we'll also unravel the latest basel
smears from the media mob
of course the number one donors to the
democratic party
tonight though it is clear democrats
they're terrified they're desperate
their candidate
we all know he's weak and feeble now
their radical socialist platform
is the most extreme of any major party
in history
the riots they once well pretty much all
out wouldn't say a negative thing about
lied about denied were even happening
they told us they were peaceful
then of course they tried to ignore them
and as a result of their lies
their failure of leadership well this is
now completely out of control
these cities and states that have been
controlled for decades by liberal
democrats are now
war zones americans of every background
every demographic every race
they are fleeing the democratic party in
droves tonight
the democratic enclave of portland
oregon just experienced yet another
night of rioting in mayhem
this time rioters attempting to burn
down a large occupied
condo building where portland's
supportive mayor of anarchy
that's mayor ted wheeler apparently
lives i wonder if fake news cnn
considers this
oh yeah see the picture look at that
picture to be a mostly peaceful fire
peaceful rioting either way the police
were forced to declare it a riot
and not before arson is starting to feed
the flames with debris
a wooden picnic table fireworks now do
keep in mind that dozens of innocent men
women and children live in that building
and guess what these far left
demonstrators
are peaceful protesters better known as
anarchists
they tried to burn it to the ground many
other buildings in the area were also
vandalized windows shattered businesses
looted
been watching this now for over a
hundred nights it was just another night
typical day typical evening in portland
oregon a city whose dopey far left mayor
and far left governor
still refuse any and all attempted help
from the president who's basically
begging them to help restore law and
order
the president keeps saying daily he
stands ready to help
any american city or state in every way
possible but he's usually unless he
invokes the insurrection act
guess what they're supposed to ask him
typically this is how it works
governors and mayors they ask for the
federal help and guess what
the president has promised to offer it
give it all
and that means mobilizing national guard
in times of lawlessness
we know how to beat back protesters
there are tools at police's disposal
non-lethal tear gas pepper spray dozens
of democratic mayors and governors
apparently would rather watch their
cities burn
than dare coordinate with president
trump it is sad it is petty
frankly repulsive and disgusting it
leads to real consequences including
death and destruction
in cities where federal help has been
requested
the violence has been squashed it has
been done
over kenosha wisconsin for example the
latest example
well order has now been restored with
the help of donald trump in the national
guard
and even kenosha's democratic mayor
admitted yup the national guard has been
extremely helpful
by the way portland new york seattle
chicago los angeles san francisco learn
from the mayor of kenosha
i will tell you though that the national
guard has been extremely helpful
and we feel comfortable that we can keep
the president safe and keep
the public safe mostly we need to try to
make sure that there's
calm in the community and that is what
we are hoping to maintain
and after request the president was able
to restore
law and order and safety and security in
minnesota
and of course our nation's capital
washington d.c that's right
the president did his job to keep people
safe and secure
sadly in kenosha before the guard was
called
in an order was restored dozens of
businesses were
absolutely wrecked with many completely
burned to the ground today the president
he toured the devastation and announced
his administration was allocating a
million dollars for local law
enforcement
4 million in aid to the businesses that
were destroyed
and 42 million to the state of wisconsin
to bolster public safety efforts
today one store owner had this to say
about the president's visit
that the mob and the media and of course
democrats are saying
can't happen it can't happen it happened
and it went along fine take a look
coming today everybody here does
we're so thankful that we got the
federal troops in to help because once
they got here
they could calm down quite a bit and our
city uh
police and sheriff and fire departments
are awesome
they work harder than you can believe
and look at your screen look at the
crowds of supporters
all in wisconsin they line the street
street after street mile after mile
to see president trump's motorcade drive
by of course joe biden
he never bothered to visit kenosha he
hasn't left
the east coast in a long time in fact
it's been if you're in wisconsin pay
attention
672 days since he last visited the great
state of wisconsin
and today by the way he took joe biden
took a long break from campaigning
he needed to west and we waxation
remember that from the cartoon
after briefly stepping out of his
basement bunker yesterday
delivering an extremely long 24-minute
speech from an empty room reading a
teleprompter
and of course followed by zero questions
from his phoning
uh press the media mob better known as
state-run media
and of course biden is now suddenly
condemning the violent riots little late
joe
remember a few weeks ago joe said he
absolutely wants to redirect funds away
from police
for months he didn't have a single nice
thing to say about
any of the brave men and women that put
their lives on the line
daily that's police around the country
that protect and serve
in very difficult circumstances the 99
percent
of good cops biden's campaign staffers
actually donated to a fund
that helped get rioters out of jail he
promises they'll have a no
bond policy nobel policy just like new
york
kamala harris actually promoted this
idiotic fund
now all of a sudden they're backtracking
63 days before an election
and joe and kamala sorry kamala are
attempting
an election time conversion but not
because they really care about the
violence and destruction
instead for them it's all about the
polls look at this
according to pew the ongoing riots are
now a top
20 20 concern for all americans and it
should be
meanwhile a brand new emerson poll shows
that trump and biden
are in a statistical dead heat the
president closing the gap among suburban
voters and minorities look at this
the president is now polling 24 percent
with african-american voters
that is three times the support he
garnered in 2016.
if that number holds this election or
re-election is over
and of course the media mobbed their
work in overtime to help rescue joe
and his struggling campaign in the last
24 hours they absolutely trashed
president trump for daring to visit
the destruction in kenosha well the
president restored order
he did it in minnesota he can do it new
york chicago portland and seattle if
they just let them take a look
tomorrow despite protests from officials
there who think his presence will only
inflame matters as protests in kenosha
enter their second week
the city braces for a controversial
presidential visit and in kenosha
officials tonight bracing for the
president's planned visit tomorrow
this is a city that has now seen days of
peace
quiet people getting along there's a lot
of unity right now
in this city and the biggest concern for
them is that to have the president come
here
it's just going to turn that all around
for a lot of people tomorrow i think
they're bracing for what's to come
and they're at fake news cnn the panic
is really setting in without a shred of
evidence
they have one of their dumb so-called
political analysts
clinton obama sycophant probably the
dumbest press secretary in history his
name joe lockhart
floating a whole new conspiracy theory
that the president of the united states
suffered a series of many strokes and
he's hiding from the american people
in broad daylight out every day
answering questions
just more lies more fake news more
conspiracy theories from cnn
the president's doctors they said one
thousand percent
false so where's the apology for yet
more lies and more hoaxes and more
conspiracies from cnn
they are just repulsive lockhart the
left they are stricken they're throwing
anything and
everything at the wall in the hopes that
something sticks look at what they
allowed this
lying jackass lockhart to say about
nicholas sandman
by the way i hope lynn sues cnn again
he's already gotten a lot of money
and by the way dr lockhart your
candidate the frail the weak joe biden
does he seem joe if you're so
intelligent does this guy seem very
mentally alert to you let's take a look
at the videotape
tomorrow's superstar tuesday and i want
to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing
if you agree with me go to joe 303
330. we choose truth over facts
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me make sure
you have the record player on at night
the the phone
make sure the kids hear words
hey dr lockhart what's your diagnosis
there now make no mistake the mob the
media the democrats they're in full
panic mode
and sadly in the next 63 days i promise
you it will only get worse
just listen to what president trump had
to say about the mob earlier today
the press should be ashamed of
themselves i think the press is actually
the media
is what's fueling this more so than even
by
because biden doesn't know he's alive
the press is really fueling this
and they're fueling it horribly and
you're doing a great disservice to your
country
they lie in unison the same words the
same phrases the same talking points
the mob the media they are the biggest
owners to all things radical democratic
socialists
and biden's answered less than 50
questions since march
and they're letting them get away with
it but let not your heart be troubled
the mob the media
guess what they are not in control of
the future
you the american people in 63 days
you have the power i don't have it they
don't have it to shock the world again